so the principal's I work on and teach
when I teach my course for people who
are reading or watching listening
etcetera is being you know just
skeptical of absolutely everything but
not equally skeptical of everything use
judgment and and I have in the back of
my mind oh when I look at media various
kinds and journalism a kind of
credibility scale it just it's just back
there or somewhere and so you can see
that at the BBC which I obviously
respect a lot is more over there on the
positive side and not universally but
there and you know BuzzFeed's all over
the place YouTube all over the place but
moving more to the negative in terms of
information quality and anonymous
comments way over on the left the thing
I want you to notice about this is that
it doesn't start at zero that anonymous
commenter would have would have to work
incredibly hard just to have no
credibility at all something sucked
credibility out of the atmosphere it's
like you know this monster thing going
on and a lot of what we're seeing now is
yanking credibility from our ecosystem
but I hope you have something like that
in mind that you don't start with zero
you can start way way in a deficit and
that it takes something to earn it you
have to do something to earn even no
credibility and that we have to ask
questions when we're doing any kind of
reading where it's going to be something
we care about whether it's to read
something else on the same topic or as
that's an email from a local official in
my town where we live in Brisbane
answering a question I had about a
situation with the water in town they
okay
I found out going outside of our comfort
zones crucial both politically and
culturally we don't do that enough we
don't look
or things that are outside of what we
believe and we don't get much help on
this from Facebook
we need more help from them in going
outside our comfort zones and we have to
be relentless with our own biases
there's a thing called confirmation bias
where we tend to believe things and if
someone points out that we're wrong with
facts we tend to believe it even more
that's really terrifying that that's
true but we there are ways to work on
impart us to recognize our biases so we
need to spend more time on these and
then finally we need to learn these
techniques of media how media are
created and by the way every teenager is
very good at that and also though how
Meteor used to persuade and manipulate
none of us is good enough
[Music]